I mean if it's all right can I bring my
uncle up yes do it yeah what's up man
come here man we're getting there
he said what
are you on you want your own we gotta do
his own we gotta do his own
oh you want your own interview
so you're not gonna come up
what's he saying what are you saying
oh yo you want to come over here come on
man come on get go ahead
first time ever take over
you took over the show yes it's no
longer bootleg catch up it's bootleg up
boo like ain't nothing boo like about me
don't get it messed up either so what
are you doing man I'm doing the bootleg
okay
so what's up man first to be done I have
three questions for you what so they're
serious questions don't be this could be
funny don't mean everything's funny
so are you ready maybe I take my
interview seriously I'm ready man I'm
ready let me get serious let me get back
to interview mode all right you ready
all right what so you know um growing up
in the um in the hood or the urban
communities however you want to address
it a lot of our kids come up
without being properly trained how to
have dreams goals and how to accomplish
them a lot of us we just go through life
trying to survive and trying to figure
it out because no one invested in US
that we can be anything we want to be
you know some people you know certain
households their their parents really
invest in them they you know they push
them to be great they um
they're enroll him and uh all these
activities as kids so they don't really
have free time to be able to run around
and do other stuff so what is something
that you would some advice that you
would give a kid about chasing dreams
um
great question I feel like the the
greatest advice is never be afraid to
dream never be afraid to be more than
what you are
never be afraid to uh venture out
outside of the walls that have us
confined to our neighborhoods when we
had our project buildings we had that
gate and in that gate we never thought
that there could be life outside of that
gate we didn't see a possibility outside
of those four corners that we called our
Hood our block it was the story it was
the school it was the turf it was the
steps and outside of that we felt like
there was nowhere place no place for us
and the greatest thing that my mother
did for me was she cultivated my
imagination she allowed me to have an
imagination because in order to surpass
those walls and those blocks and those
Corners that we come from the only way
they were able to fly over them is
through our imagination
and my greatest advice to these children
to these kids to parents to big homies
to anybody that comes from our areas
never corrupt a child's imagination
allow them to do that like I told a
person on Christmas you believe that you
know whatever you believe in allow that
child to believe in sin allow that girl
to have her imaginary friend that she
talks to that doll that she talks to
allow that kid to you know imagine right
imagine because sometimes your
imagination is the only thing that can
get you out of those situations yeah
because you can become so consumed by
what your day the reality is of course
you know reality around you that you
that a drink like something that you
would think is possible for you you
would think that your situation in life
what won't make it takes you out of the
uh equation you know to reach those
things for sure why so serious today
though I thought you was gonna get on
here no I got another question nephew of
you taking over his own interview what
do you mean why are you he ain't
sweating me why are you sweating me
what's the next question so the next
question is right nephew along our
journey in life a lot of things happen
that we may not be ready for we not we
may not be um willing or ready to take
on but we have no choice because
um it's just what comes with their our
journey in life like we don't be able to
pick what's ahead of us right we we only
can prepare ourselves to deal with it
when we get there
I don't like to use the word regret so
I'm gonna say what is one mistake you
may have made in your rap career that
you can explain that may give another
up-and-coming rapper
um some knowledge on what maybe he might
not want to do when it comes to his
career that may
um prevent him from you know maybe um
shortening his career maybe making it
take go a little slower like what is
something what is the mistake that you
may have made that somebody else may be
able to get something out of the
difference between confidence and
arrogance
coming up
I've always been confident all right
but sometimes we don't understand that
there's a difference between confidence
and arrogance arrogance is uh
it's a it's a thin line between being
humble and being hubris and that
arrogance is the thing that offends
people right and you're intentionally
sliding someone just because you may
want them to look at you a certain way
or you want them to put some certain
respect on it and there's no need to do
that like if you're a good person
there's no need to treat anyone bad
right just because you got money don't
mean that you need to look down on
people and I think in the early stages
of my career I allow my arrogance to
override my natural confidence because
you can still be confident and still be
a humble individual yeah because I was
going to have an extra I was going to
add on to that do you think that some
people be arrogant because personally
they don't have they that they're really
not as confident as they think they lack
confidence so they really they really
try to uh be macho what they are they
they're confident they try to be macho
because they because confidence come
with like a control Factor right you
understand me and it teaches you I'm
confident enough to know that when I
come in here I don't have to be arrogant
right I never thought that I was better
than anyone but I knew that I worked
harder
and sometimes
that can
activate some people's insecurities
right and then your arrogance
overrides it so now they look at
confidence is Steph Curry pulling up
from half court feeling like I can make
the shot right
some people would be like oh he arrogant
he shot it from one nah that's just
confidence yeah because when they asked
him man why did you shoot that shot I
felt like I could make it right all
right it wasn't oh I knew I could make
it I won't nah that arrogance sometimes
is a sucker complex yeah that's what I
mean I'm saying yeah you you a suck a
complex where the guys that act hell are
tough or the females that at caliber
most of the girls that be mean as hell
be real sweethearts right that's their
defense mechanism so I allow my
arrogance to become a defense mechanism
and um I offended certain individuals
and I'm thankful that I did it because
it taught me the lesson because I
wouldn't be able to know right so uh
there's no regret to it um but it was
just a mistake it wasn't one of us yeah
it was it was a mistake a mistake you
know and you learn from it right and and
you build on
okay and my last question is this if you
had the opportunity to um
to really be able to uh do an album or
or participate or write or do anything
musically with one artist who would that
artist be and why Sam Cook to me Sam
Cook was the greatest uh artist of our
time and it wasn't my time but just of
that genre of music Soul music
um Not only was Sam Cooke uh
a great artist he was a brilliant
songwriter but something that trumps all
of that is at a time where black men
didn't own their music where black men
didn't have anything the black artists
at that time would receive pennies this
man owned his own label right he owned
his own label he signed his own artists
he did a lot of things that was uh he
trumped everyone that was around at that
time
Soulful he was a superstar he was a
super duper Star
um and
I would love to do something with Sam
Cook man like Sam Cooke to me
um he was the greatest man but uh I love
your questions I love your seriousness
good job and I appreciate people leg
care for letting us rock man the airway
let's wrap it up let's wrap it up man
let's listen the next time I see you I
need some of these oh my gosh Hey Hey
listen we got we got you on the dope
area everything and we would love for
you to come up man so next time I'm in
the bay I I'll be out there soon we're
gonna do so what what I've been doing
um
we've been doing these things to just
help the artists I'll be out there to
watch the Suns eliminate you guys in the
playoffs so yeah
wow I'm gonna catch a game go watch you
know go watch Katie come back well if
that's the case we need to take
advantage of him coming to see famous
loops and why there do something amazing
we're gonna throw something let's do it
yeah let's do it we're gonna do the
watch party at the club right whatever
we got to do go to the game I'll be
super excited to watch you guys lose to
the suns in the playoffs this year yeah
can I ask you a question huh
do you honestly think that Phoenix is
going to win like let's talk sports okay
okay okay okay if Katie is if everyone's
Health wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait you're talking about a
Phoenix Suns team that were able to
reach the semi-conference finals without
a KD so now it's a if KD
well first of all we just got rid of Cam
Johnson and Mikhail Bridges who were
very important parts of that team okay
two
Kevin Durant is healthy I don't think
anyone's gonna beat us
you know a little something about
putting a little extra on top of a team
that was already on fire 73-9 and nine
team adding Kevin Durant so you know you
and I were both the same now yeah but
the only thing is we have I had a ring
before him I yeah but that was because
Kyrie Irving Kevin Love were [__] up
are we gonna use because
shout out to dellavedova still gave
Steph some help let's just be listen
this is just crazy we find any way to
say to take away we had a ring before
Katie and we have a ring after Katie so
now
is the pressure on female can I be
honest with you or the one the most
important and best ring you guys won was
last year's ring yeah it was a great
Ring no that's the best ring you guys
ever won because there's no there's no
caveat or asterisk to that ring
so there's an aspect to our other Rings
because of injuries because people
weren't able to endure a full season and
stay healthy that's our fault
like I said
on the court last year is your most
respected ring you've got can you at
least agree on that I love that ring
last year but do you think it's the most
and when it comes to Integrity nobody
could say [__] about last year
you guys were you guys nobody gave you
guys a chance you guys won the [__]
Championship you played a great Celtics
team who are the favorites this year
and there was no there was no
Shenanigans I love that ring I love last
year's ring I love the effort
collectively that the fellas did um
um we were able to you know I don't know
what it's like to have a championship I
know that sucks I don't even know what
that is like never understand this
conversation
um but the beauty of it is I think the
ring that we missed out on was the most
important to me which is crazy like the
73-9 yeah that was that was
heartbreaking um it's okay because you
guys added KD to that team and then yeah
it was and then you ruined the league
for a couple weeks sometimes a loss that
humbles you is far greater than a win
that adds to your arrogance well I sure
hope that we ruin the league for the
next few years too with it it's not
gonna happen like Chris Chris Paul's not
a winner
here we go he's never won anything he
didn't win at Georgia Tech he did he's
never won he never won in New Orleans
he's never won in La when he had the
greatest one what Blake Griffin and
DeAndre Jordan it was alley-oop Central
Lobster not the greatest though I mean
for that time an athletic in his prime
Blake Griffin dunking over anyone all
you got to do is throw the ball up and
you couldn't win you lose you come down
3-1 you lose that they had bad injury
luck man Chris Paul will forever had bad
luck somewhere except this year
somewhere along life you know I'm saying
the only thing that he did was what he
did and hmm
what he did to that woman and how do you
feel about uh how do you feel about uh
this is are we can we make a prediction
that this is draymond's final year with
the Warriors No you think he's Stan
um I think the Warriors organization
know how important they know um how
important Draymond is um I think he
wants to go to the Lakers and play with
his best bud man I think he definitely
wants to go to the Lakers just based off
the fact Rich Paul and his whole
management agency team his bestie and
you know and LeBron him and LeBron are
definitely friends but he would have
thought that they'd be ended up being
best friends after he nailed him in the
nuts and cost him the ring here we go
yeah
um who would have thought and then
they're gonna end up playing together
next year it's going to be Draymond and
Dilo and A.D you know what's weird Ron
if the Warriors don't pay Bob Myers then
Draymond leaves true if I heard that he
might leave he he might go to the Lakers
um
you know he might go to the Lakers so if
I just can't wait for your Dynasty to be
over because I I have no nothing against
fans from the Bay who are Warrior
supporters but it's these [__] you
guys are like the new Cowboys fans it's
crazy dealing with Warriors fans who
aren't from the [__] Bay is
ridiculous oh
like I mean it's it's like it's like
it's like John Cena fans more Warriors
fans of course you're a [__] John
Cena fan that's real [__] convenient
are you more are you mad because there's
more Warrior fans at the Suns game do
you see that that's 10 years old but all
right listen is that a Joe Smith Jersey
buddy that's Tyrone Hill buddy Tyrone
Hill okay first of all Joe Smith were
the same number right most definitely
what happened that just lets you know
how long ago that was brother I didn't
say you were in a real no I'm just
saying because I I just feel like I have
right to talk about this conversation
regardless if our dynasty was supposed
to be over when we when Steph was
hurting we only won I was excited I was
excited so you want to see us lose for
sure why I [__] hate the Warriors man
that's crazy how did the Phoenix Suns
Phoenix Suns fan establish this much
hatred for the Warriors you know why
because my favorite player is that guy
right there the statue LeBron James I
love LeBron yeah
listen the suns were like the [__]
Dan Marley I love Kevin Johnson I like
Charles Barkley I love Cedric sabales I
love Wayman Tisdale I'm a real wow
I'm real basketball Tisdale on the
Warriors no he didn't play first he
played for the Suns no but he wasn't on
the Warriors for a little bit um
all right no so like he was when he was
on the Suns he put out a jazz album yeah
he did he played the bass yeah uh I I I
love the Phoenix Suns I love you know I
love what you do I love Tom Chambers
everything that you got I could never
see myself wanting to see a team just
deliberately lose I don't know that's
where you and I yeah are different
because I do I want to see the Warriors
January 27th and you're an aquarius how
can this be I'm an aquarius why are you
act like this I [__] hate the
Warriors it's crazy yeah I'm over it
we're going to continue this Sports show
I'm over this [__] man
hey man thank you though brother of
course bro I appreciate you yes sir man
um as always nothing but love Northern
California Southern California let's
continue to keep be able to create and
show the world man that California is
amen we're one of the most creative
places in the world let's continue to
keep working together artists and keep
building uh and Central Cali pay these
high taxes and yes definitely expensive
to live here man uncan Fab show going
worldwide man and uh I thank you man
thank you appreciate it there it is